we've mentioned previously that joe
biden
came into office or his first approval
rating once in office
was the highest initial approval rating
of any president in nearly 30 years in
fact
28 to be exact dating back to bill
clinton's first
year in the white house in 1993.
it is now not just one poll yesterday's
politico morning consult poll
continues to have joe biden polling very
strongly let's take a look at the full
scope of the numbers right now joe biden
with
62 percent approval 62
approval remember donald trump did not
get to 50
approval even once during his entire
presidency
the coveted relief bill once passed
still
roughly the same level of support 72
percent of americans
supporting the covid relief bill 56
percent of americans
believe joe biden is doing a good job on
the economy typical that democratic
presidents don't poll that well
on the economy that's a long-standing uh
statistical reality 66 approval for joe
biden on coronavirus remaining in that
mid to high
60s level so these are very
strong numbers and seeing joe biden's
approval on coronavirus stimulus
reminded me once again not a single
republican voted for that bill many
republican voters
supporting coveted relief zero
republican votes in the house of
representatives
zero republican votes in the senate for
this coveted relief bill
and so that gets us to the question of
whether republicans
need to recalibrate their thinking on
voting against something that you have
essentially a super majority of the
country wanting supporting and needing
the answer may not be yes and what i
mean by that is
if republican no votes in the house and
senate on covid relief
which is popular have no consequences in
2022
why would they vote for it if there is a
political case to be made for i voted
against the pork
and i voted against the you know
overspending and what about the dead and
what about the desert you know whatever
if it's not going to affect them in 2022
with their own base
and i remain skeptical that it will
maybe republicans don't need to
recalibrate their votes to be reflective
of what their constituents want i don't
know
given the circumstances the situation
joe biden was handed the hyper
polarization of the country and
and a party the republican party that
has been
feeding a lie uh to their voters for two
months that joe biden
actually won given all of that these are
really good numbers
they may not remain i said before if
biden doesn't get coveted stimulus done
soon like within i said you know about a
week ago i said within 10 days or
14 days ago i said within 10 days and it
passed last week
if biden doesn't get it done it would be
a major failure and it will probably
tank his approval
he got it done people are getting cash
and they don't care
you know if you just got 1400 or 2800 or
whatever
do you care if it happened via budget
reconciliation or you got the money
because of 60 votes
no people don't care about that outside
of
you know the political beltway and
people who follow politics really
closely and this probably buys biden
six weeks eight weeks and then the
question becomes
what next does a vaccine roll out
continue to improve
because cases are starting to level out
even though we're vaccinating we have to
vaccinate more quickly
we'll have to see what the next thing is
for joe biden and by the way
these numbers 62 approval etc
biden has these numbers without even
doing a press conference
fox news and newsmax and others would
have you believe
that joe biden not having done a press
conference yet
uh is essentially the biggest scandal
since watergate at this point in time
it's not something that most american
people care about most american people
don't even watch presidential press
briefings however
joe biden will be doing one a week from
today thursday the 25th
and of course i will be covering it the
day after joe biden's press conference
the 26th
we're doing a one-day membership special
we are
blowing out huge discounts these
discounts are not illegal
but they're definitely immoral in some
sense i'm kidding
march 26th big discount if you want to
be notified about it to get a membership
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com and then friday morning
next friday morning you will be given
specific instructions
how to sign up for this disgustingly
discounted membership
the more we learn about various diets
around the world
the more we realize that some of the
healthiest diets where folks are living
the healthiest and the longest
are heavily plant-based and one of our
sponsors
just egg is a great place to start just
egg
cooks and tastes just like real eggs
but it's made from plants it has less
saturated fat
no cholesterol packed with protein i've
been cooking with just egg
at home and you can use it in so many
different ways
just like traditional eggs omelets
scrambled eggs french toast
banana bread one of my favorite dishes
pad thai
it also is better for the planet
generating 93 percent
fewer carbon emissions and 98 percent
less
water than conventional eggs you can
find just egg at lots of grocery stores
whole foods kroger
amazon prime now and instacart
check it out just egg really is a great
product from a company with a great
mission and i'm really glad that they're
a sponsor of the show